RACHAEL O'MEARA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Rachael O'Meara.
I'm really excited today to be
hosting an Authors at Google
event, Talks at Google.
We have Marianne Williamson here
today, and she's here to
talk about her latest work,
"How to Overcome Financial
Stress and Live a Life
of Abundance".
Marianne, if you aren't familiar
with her work, is one
of our greatest spiritual
leaders right now, motivator,
a lecturer, in general, someone
who is making a big
difference in the world.
So if anyone here is familiar
with her work, that's awesome.
And if not, hopefully you'll
come away from today learning
a few things about how you can
live a life of abundance.
Her latest book-- it's called
"The Law of Divine
Compensation"--
is available in the back.
And "Return to Love", which is
one of her earlier works, is
also available in the back.
And I'll just leave
with this comment.
I think it's really important
at Google that we bring in
authors that challenge what we
think, and speakers who have
open agendas and really just
make a difference in our
culture at Google to really be
pushing the envelope and
figuring out what's best, what
we can do and how we can help.
So Marianne is here for
that reason today.
And if anyone saw the movie
"Coach Carter", she has a
quote in there that I really
enjoy and I wanted to share
with you before we
get started.
So what is in the movie is the
following, and this is
Marianne's quote.
"Our deepest fear is not
that we are inadequate.
Our deepest fear is that we are
powerful beyond measure.
It is our light, not
our darkness, that
most frightens us".
So with that, I'll leave
you with Marianne.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON:
Thank you, Rachael.
Thank you.
Thank you so much
for having me.
I tell you, I forget that I had
told Rachael I would be
talking about abundance
and financial stress.
We'll get there, because I'm
going to instead go with what,
since apparently I wrote that
email, I've been thinking
about that I want to
share with you.
But as you'll also recognize,
it's all one big
conversation anyway.
So let's start with this
conversation about creativity
and leadership.
Creativity, the way the Western
mind usually thinks of
creating something, we think
of ourselves as being
generative.
And we think, I need to
go create something.
Certainly at a company like
this, you're thinking about
that a lot.
We got to create something.
Now a lot of this has to do
with, you could talk about it
as a worldly perspective
versus a more spiritual
perspective.
In a very real way, it's a
more Western perspective
rather than an Eastern
perspective.
The idea of creativity
being generative is a
very Western concept.
It's like the thought that if
you bring a blank document up
on your screen and you've
got to figure out
what to write on it.
What am I going to create
on this document?
A more spiritual or metaphysical
prospective says,
there's already a file.
And your job is to download
the file.
And it is an undelete-able
file.
And it is creativity itself.
Hemingway was famous for having
talked about how unless
the story was writing itself,
he put the pencil down.
He would write, he said, every
day for as long a period of
time as the story seemed to be
writing itself through him.
Once he felt that that was no
longer happening, he put the
pencil down.
And of course, in that fabulous
book, "Letters to a
Young Poet", the poet Rilke,
when asked by the young poet,
how do I know if I should
be a poet even?
Rilke's response was, only
be a poet if you have to.
Only if it is the calling that
is within you that is
undeniable.
Also in the Eastern religions,
in Zen Buddhism, of course,
whereas in the Western mind we
think of learning everything I
need to learn so that then I can
make something happen, the
highest creative moment in Zen
Buddhism is the empty mind.
The Zen mind in Buddhism is
called the beginner's mind.
So the practice of the East,
or the practice of
spirituality, is to take all
that you've learned, you learn
it just so that then
you can forget it.
Now it's still there, so that's
not a reason to not
become educated.
It's not a reason to not
read the books and
get the skill set.
But the practice of the creative
mind is to enter into
the moment without
that clutter.
In the I Ching they talk about
presenting an empty
rice bowl to God.
An empty rice bowl.
Now it's the same thing., the
idea of an empty rice bowl,
because it's said in the
east that the Dao will
fill the rice bowl.
But if you enter in the moment
thinking you already know,
then that higher force of
creativity, by whatever you
call it, cannot work
through you.
It does actually have a
corresponding metaphysical
principle in the New Testament,
when Jesus said, be
as little children.
Because in the course in
miracles, he says, what that
means is little children know
that they do not know, and so
they are teachable.
Where adults too often walk into
a situation thinking that
they do know, and so they're not
teachable, which I think,
by the way, is even more of a
psychic crisis for males than
females in our society.
Because men are so bred--
we're all embarrassed to say
that we don't know, but men,
particularly, it's almost like
they must act like they know.
And that particular aspect of
the mind is actually very
detrimental to us.
Because the mind that thinks it
knows is not the mind that
ultimately knows.
Because the mind that ultimately
knows is the mind
that, as it were, is receptive
to a higher
vibration of knowledge.
Now leadership fits
in to that.
Because in the Dao to Ching,
Lao Tzu said, to be a
follower-- the way to
be a leader of men--
is to be a follower
of the Dao.
So if you think of yourself--
it's counter intuitive--
if you're thinking of yourself
as here to follow something
higher, you manifest as a leader
among other people.
If you act like someone who's
trying to be a leader, people
kind of wonder what
your game is.
Because like, what are
you trying to do?
Because particularly today, with
this switch over out of
the top down model, we're moving
into the idea of-- we
have moved into the idea of
leadership as someone who
holds a space for the brilliance
of others.
Now if-- that's what
leadership is.
Leadership is I hold
the space, I
assume you're brilliant.
That's the best thing-- if
you're a leader on a team, the
best thing you can do
is to assume that
everybody there is a genius.
Now the notion, metaphysically.
Is that all minds are joined,
that on a level of energy and
mind, there's really no place
where you stop and I start.
Everybody subconsciously
knows everything.
If I'm sitting in a room with
you-- this goes way beyond
behavior modification--
because if I'm sitting in a room
with you, no matter how
nice I'm being to you, if I
really assume you have some
real limits, you know that on
some level, whether you even
consciously know it or not.
But if I'm assuming that you,
like everyone, has only
scratched the surface of genius
that lies inside all of
us, that is the word salute.
That's what salute means.
I salute you.
I re-cognize that, recognize
that in you.
And in my presence--
it's kind of like when you go
to therapy, and you might be
at a therapeutic session and at
the end of the session, you
say to your therapist, oh,
thank you, thank you.
This was so good for me.
Thank you.
The therapist had hardly
said a word.
You ever had those times?
It was the quality of their
compassion and non-judgment.
In the presence, that's what
their skill set was.
The quality of their compassion
and non-judgment
called you.
And so if a leader is simply
assuming that you're a genius,
assuming that genius lies within
you, that you have the
potential for greatness, it
literally, in the presence of
that person who is assuming the
best in you, you will rise
to that level.
Now, once again, I wasn't
seeking to lead you.
I was seeking to follow
an inner light.
Now you can talk about that
inner light or inner
understanding in secular
terms or religious
terms, spiritual terms.
It's so irrelevant, the
language that we use.
The point is that we're
beginning to understand that
there are-- what did I say, we
use 10% of the brain cells--
that there are expanded
dimensions of consciousness,
and that when we enter into
those dimensions of
consciousness, whether it's
through meditation,
mindfulness, which is like the
politically correct way of
expressing meditation today,
prayer, whatever our practice
is, the idea is that we
literally-- it's a conversion.
It's just like converting
in electricity.
You're converting into
the wisdom mind.
You're converting out of
the strategic mind.
the formulaic mind.
And this is what people are
finally beginning to
understand.
When you're converting out of
the rational, or beyond the
rational, you're not going into
the irrational, you're
just going into the
non-rational.
The non-rational is
not irrational.
Look at nature.
Look at how nature
always takes care
of its young, right?
What is rational about a society
of geniuses that
spends so much more effort on
keeping people down, harming
people we don't like,
incarcerating if they mess up?
What's rational about this?
It is insane.
So if you get a bunch of
rational, so-called rational,
people together who do not
have a sense of serving a
higher good, you come up with
irrational actions and
irrational behavior.
And that is where we have come
to in our society and in our
civilization, even when you
look at something like
technology.
Technology, the idea of the
material plane from a
spiritual perspective is that
there's nothing on the
spiritual plane that is either
holy or unholy, high minded or
low minded, except as the mind
ascribes purpose to it.
Nobody needs to be reminded in
this room the incredibly good
things that technology
can do for the world.
But nobody needs to be reminded
in this room either
the very destructive ways
that people can use
technology, as well.
This is where Western
civilization,
particularly, is.
This is where we are.
We have all this, but the crisis
now is the crisis of
significance and the crisis
of importance.
And will we use what we have
done in our society over the
last 40 years or so is that we
have taken the prodigious
genius and education and
capacity of generations of
Americans, the most privileged
in a very long time, and used
it primarily for unimportant
ends.
And there are a lot of
sociological and political
reasons for that, but the
analysis of how we got here is
not as important as that
we start anew.
And in starting anew, we're
really moving out-- many
people are moving out of the
sense of I don't know, I'll do
whatever I want to do.
Now the I don't know, I'll do
whatever I want to do-- when
you look at the Middle Ages, the
Middle Ages was dominated
by a church structure that
was imprisoning and
limiting to the mind.
And it had a particular world
view, and anybody who didn't
toe the line with their world
view was cast out, at best,
and tortured and killed,
at worse.
The Enlightenment,
the 18th Century
enlightenment, was so important.
And this country was founded of
it. it was the idea of, no,
the human being of themselves,
without a church sitting on
top of them, can use
reasoning, can do
whatever they want.
But Heidl said, it's thesis,
antithesis, synthesis.
Because now we realized we had
taken what is really a
positive character, a logical
image of the rugged
individualist, and we've taken
it so far that now we're like
the cancer cell which
has gone insane.
And instead of recognizing its
natural intelligence which
would lead it to collaborate
with other cells for the
healthy functioning of the
organ, the cancer cell is a
cell that says, I don't
want to do that.
I'm want to go do
my own thing.
I don't want to just collaborate
with other cells
to serve the healthy functioning
of the spleen.
I want to go do my own thing.
And that is malignant.
And it just gathers other
sick cells around it.
That forms a mass, which is then
destructive, not only to
that organ, but to the
entire system and
ultimately, to itself.
And that is where the Western
mind has gone.
An individualist mentality has
become malignant mentality.
It's one thing to be an
individual and to know that
I'm a unique expression,
as all of us are.
That's a beautiful thing.
But even the rose knows it's
part of a larger garden.
You have the rose and you have
the tulip and you have the
peony and you have the
daisy and all that.
But then there's this thing
called the garden, and they
all belong within the garden.
The malignant thinking of
Western consciousness is that
we have thought, it's
just about me.
We've put competition
above collaboration.
We have forgotten that there's
a bigger purpose here than
just me getting what I want.
So I think that's this era
of history that we're in.
Because we realize--
and I think that there is an
awakening in our society, and
I think, around the world, of
people recognizing that
whatever mentality has been
dominating things has taken
us, literally, not figuratively,
literally, to
the brink of disaster.
Literally.
There are so many
stress points.
There are so many very, very
grim probability vectors for
the next 20 years.
And I think that all that's--
I wouldn't say all that's
needed, but really the primary
foundational thing that's
needed is that shift in
thinking, from I don't
have these toys.
You here--
if this were something happening
centuries ago,
Google would be seen as a wizard
school, like Hogwarts.
You are carrying--
this is wizardry.
This is what would have
been called wizardry.
But the issue that you would
see, if it was centuries ago,
there would be a conversation,
is it the dark arts or the
light arts?
And I think the blessing on a
company like this, from a
metaphysical perspective, is
that there already is the
conversation, we want to make
people's lives better.
But even that, I think the
next iteration is beyond
making just individuals'
lives better.
How are we going to keep this
ship that we're on from
hitting the iceberg?
Now Rachael mentioned my last
book, "The Law of Divine
Compensation".
So in that I talk about
a principle I want
to move into now.
From the metaphysical
perspective--
and meta means beyond.
So there's the physical,
as above, so below.
The notion is that there are
objective, discernible laws of
the internal realms of
consciousness, just as there
are objective, discernible laws
of the external world.
Gravity, thermodynamics.
Same with the internal
phenomenon.
Nothing in this world, even
the mysteries, are not
mysterious if you
understand them.
The notion of a self-organizing
universe is
that you see certain
imprints in nature.
The embryo, the way
it becomes a baby.
The bud, the way it
becomes a blossom.
The acorn, the way it
becomes an oak tree.
A little acorn is programmed
within.
A little acorn is already
carrying a blueprint by which
it will one day turn into an
oak tree, a huge oak tree.
The embryo.
You have one sperm.
You have one egg.
And even though we can make
pictures of it, the mystery by
which it is programmed, somehow
those cells are going
to divide and become a brain and
become a heart and become
lungs and become eyeballs and
become skull and become hair
and become skin and become
a vascular system.
I mean, it's phenomenal.
And it's going to be put in this
tiny little package to
come out through woman's legs.
I mean, the whole thing is a
level of genius that is so
beyond anything that we
have come up with.
The metaphysical notion is that
it is not just the cells
and an embryo becoming a baby.
It is not just the bud becoming
a blossom or the
acorn becoming the oak tree, but
that every single aspect
of nature, there is an imprint
of self-organization.
Not only self-organization,
but self-correction.
What that means is, just as the
cell is programmed, its
own native intelligence,
when it is sane.
We've already talked about
an insane cell.
It's called a cancer-ed cell.
But a sane cell is recognizing
its natural programming by
which it collaborates with the
other cells to serve the
healthy functioning.
From a metaphysical perspective,
you and I are all
cells, also naturally programmed
to collaborate with
others in order to serve the
healthy functioning of the
total organism, which is life
on the planet as we know it.
We had been taught an
insane perspective.
And that's what Gandhi said.
The problem with the world is
humanity's out his mind.
So when we are not thinking,
how can I
serve, we are insane.
And when we do think, how can I
serve, it literally performs
a conversion in the brain.
So if you go into
any meeting--
and this is what--
I love what's happening in the
world today, because what
people are doing today is that
they're casting on to what I'm
about to say, it's woo woo.
But actually ripping it off and
turning it into all kinds
of leadership seminars and stuff
like that, and say, but
we're not woo woo.
When actually, they're saying
the exact same things that the
people they call woo
woo were saying.
This projection onto love
and spirituality,
it's just woo woo.
It's light brain.
It's fuzzy brain thinking.
As though, like I said, it's
really intelligent to just
incarcerate everybody that acts
out of their desperation
or bomb people who dare to
disagree with you, right?
So that's really saying.
But the idea here is that
when your attitude, your
perspective is, before you walk
into a meeting, that you
just send your peace
to everybody
who's going to be there.
You send your love before you.
For some people, that's
saying a prayer.
For some people, it's
a blessing.
For some people, just sending
peace, sending good energy,
wishing you the best,
beneficent, namaste.
That's another thing
with Americans.
If we say it in another
language, we'll accept it.
[LAUGHTER]
Particularly in Northern
California.
Fine.
Whatever.
Whatever it does for you.
The love in me salutes
the love in you.
The Christ in me
salutes Christ.
God in me salutes God in you.
The Buddha within me salutes
the Buddha within you.
It truly does not matter.
It's that the wisdom in me and
the love in me and the
goodness in me--
you will literally have
a different meeting.
And what it does is it plugs
everybody into their natural
intelligence.
Now the idea of the law of
divine compensation is not
only is the universe
self-organizing, which means
just as every cell in the embryo
is already programmed
to turn into the baby, that
perspective holds that you and
I are already programmed, each
and every one of us, to become
fully self-actualized.
The oak tree is the full
self-actualization of the acorn.
And the blossom is the full
self-actualization of the bud.
And the baby is the full
self-actualization of the embryo.
The person you're capable
of being is your
self-actualized self.
And you are programmed to be the
man or the woman that you
are capable of being on this
planet, this lifetime, no less
than the embryo is programmed
to be the baby.
But the difference between us
and the acorn and the embryo
is that you and I can say,
no, I don't want to.
That's what free will means.
I don't have to.
I don't have to think the
thoughts of complete service
and compassion and love.
I can say, no, I'm only
here for myself.
I'm only here to
get something.
And I have an idea of what I
need to make happen, which is
always based on something that
happened in my past that I
need to compensate for,
that's why I think I
need to make it happen.
Therefore, my core belief is
that things really aren't good
enough already.
Therefore, no matter what
I do, I will recreate a
situation in which things are
not good enough already.
So the attitude of, I'm
only here to love is
hardly woo woo thinking.
It's the most sophisticated
thinking.
I have no agenda.
I'm empty.
How can I serve?
Wow, you're incredible.
And dear God, if there's any
part of me that can't see how
incredible she is, please remove
that obstruction, in
whatever language.
And then you are literally
in a parallel universe of
possibility.
And that's what's happening on
the planet, I think, is that
we are seeking, some in
religious and spiritual ways,
and some in secular ways, to
return to that natural
intelligence, whether it's
through mindfulness, whether
it's through meditation,
whether it's
through spiritual practice.
And even more importantly that
we remember that when you do
meditate, when you do align
yourself with these kinds of
ideas, the point is not just to
be there while you're doing
your practice, it's what happens
when you open your
eyes, you go back
into the world.
So that if I'm in a business
meeting with you, I'm looking
at you, thinking, the love in
me salutes the love in you.
If I'm in a business meeting
with you, I'm thinking, wow,
boy, my judgments
are really high.
That's blocking the
possibilities that could
happen here.
I'm really willing to see
this differently.
You train your brain.
You train your mind into a
different perspective.
The universe is self-organizing,
yes.
It's also self-correcting.
And that means that just like
once that baby, once the
embryo turns into the baby, once
the body is born and the
lungs continue to breathe and
the heart continues to beat,
the body also has an immune
system, so that if injury or
illness enters into the system,
the immune system is
there to take care
of the problem.
We also, the psychic
bloodstream, as it were, of
humanity, we also have
an immune system.
An immune system takes the form
of conscience, remorse,
moral concern and so forth.
That's why it's such a
conversation in a society
about sociopaths.
Sociopaths and narcissists.
They're cancerous cells.
It's a malignant mentality,
because it's only
concerned for self.
There's a lot of talk in society
today, don't feel bad.
With some people in some
situations, feel bad.
Because only a sociopath would
not feel bad in this moment.
Conscience is there
for a reason.
Remorse is there for a reason.
Nature provides us with these
things as a way of bells are
ringing and lights
are flashing.
No, it's not OK.
It's not OK that 17,000 children
are starving on this
planet every day.
It's not OK.
It's not OK that America
has 2.4 million people
incarcerated, that there are
more African American men
incarcerated today than there
were enslaved in 1850.
It's not OK.
It's not OK that one
in four American
children are food insecure.
It's not OK.
That's not something that a
Google thing is going to come
up on your computer and
say, it's not OK.
It's not OK.
But if you say it's not OK,
then when you consider the
wizardry of things like Google
and the extraordinary
technological advances that have
come about, then we can
handle all those problems.
And that's why a place like
this is so important.
I heard a man say not too long
ago-- he is a medical doctor--
and he was dealing with these
extraordinary machines that
are doing all the stuff with the
stem cells and the genome.
And it's just amazing what
medical research
is coming up with.
But he was talking about the
irony, and he's so right.
The work we do to save one life,
and then we so casually
destroy many.
That is an insanity factor, and
no machine can fix that.
But when we allow our hearts and
minds to be aligned and we
become deeply rational--
there's a line in the course
in miracles where it says,
love restores reason and not
the other way around.
And we see that all the
technological and material
resources, such as a Google,
such as technology, are here
to be used in service to that,
then there's nothing
that we cannot do.
Now the issue of abundance is
that that is the abundance.
That is the abundance.
This mentality is
the abundant.
And when you are living in
that internal abundance,
Martin Luther King said, you
are surrounded by cosmic
companionship.
When you're just trying to make
things happen, you're not
creating anything.
You're making something.
You're staying on the mortal
plane and you're at the effect
and will continue to be at the
effect of the laws of chaos
and randomness.
And good luck and I
hope you do well.
When you convert to, I'm here
no more and no less than any
other human being for purposes
much greater than my mortal
mind has any idea, I carry
within me no more and no less
infinite potential for
brilliance and genius.
I am programmed no more and no
less than every other person
to be the highest actualization
of my
possibility on this
planet, manifest
creatively in this lifetime.
And that as I do that, I will
naturally just as cells find
themselves in the presence of
other cells who know to
collaborate with them to do what
they do for the healthy
functioning of the body, to the
extent that I'm living at
that higher frequency of
possibility, I will then
naturally resonate with
people who also play
in the higher game.
And we are all programmed, not
necessarily through what our
rational mind can determine, but
through our hearts, with
the rational mind in
service to that.
And then not only do we
actualize, but we become a
huge corrective force
for a planet that is
absolutely in trouble.
Many years ago, when I was a
teenager, I was accosted in my
house, a man who broke into
my parents' home.
And when this happened, and I
was in my bedroom and he came
in the door, I had an
experience where
every cell was alive.
Every cell was alive.
And I really had an experience
how the human is programmed
when there is real disaster.
Every cell of me was alive.
I was catapulted
into behavior--
and what 17-year-old girl
even knows, right?
And I think that that's what's
happening on this planet.
I feel it.
There's a quickening.
I used to think, just, God,
we would all say,
Americans are so asleep.
I don't think we're
asleep anymore.
I think there's a critical
mass-- there's enough people
who, like, get the--
it's like storm warnings.
And now, for us, remember we are
programmed to be able to
handle this.
An immune system knows
what to do.
And AIDS was a fascinating
metaphysical, just as cancer
is a fascinating representation
of where
consciousness has gone off, so
is a suppressed immune system.
We have forgotten, we are
the immune system.
And when we see ourselves that
way and just have that action
within, it sparks something.
It sparks something in the heart
and it sparks something
in the brain, and it makes
other people perceive us
differently.
Then what will happen,
I think, is
that we'll get going.
And there is no doubt.
I think we've already started.
I just think we need
to step it up.
And obviously, companies like
this, and anything that has to
do with technology, is part of
what not only can go right in
individual's lives, but can be
used in a collective way
beyond anything you've even come
up with yet to turn the
ship around, so that
collectively we do more than
we're doing now.
What we're doing now is that one
force, people and forces
in America, seem determined to
just throw us over the cliff.
Another force is trying hard
to keep us from the cliff.
What we need to do
is just walk in a
different direction entirely.
And the universe is not only
organized and knows how to
organize and it is
self-organizing, but within
the infinity of spiritual
substance, there are also the
capacity to compensate
for any lack or any
problem, when it exists.
And that divine compensation not
only makes sure that you
personally are taken care of,
but something much more
important happens than just that
you are financially and
career-wise taken care of.
And that's that we become a
generation that saves the
entire species from global
catastrophe, which it is
absolutely not unreasonable to
consider possible, if not
probable, at this time.
Does that make sense?
So what I'd like to do, since
there's a microphone right
there, what I'd like to do with
the time we have left is
for anybody who wants to, come
to the mic to either bring up
a topic or ask a question
within this, and
we'll talk about it.
From a spiritual perspective,
this idea of the shift, the
conversion, the shift from fear
to love is nothing short
of a miracle.
Because that miracle has to do
with the reprogramming of
thought system so that
possibilities exist within
time and space that would
otherwise have not existed.
AUDIENCE: So thank you for all
of that great insight.
For folks who are looking to
start that conversation, like
you said, here at Google, we've
got a lot of analytical
minds and outside of Google,
there's just
all types of folks.
So how do you just start it,
if there's a question that
maybe you know others that might
be interested or even
not even close to where this
is right now, what you're
talking about, they're just
not in that mindset.
Can you give us some tips on
how would you start that?
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: OK.
Now this is what's
interesting here.
Self-organizing universe.
Each of us are cells, so
each of us has natural
intelligence.
Each of us has a part to play.
Like every cell in the body
has a part to play.
Not only does it have its part
to play, but no other
cell has that part.
So that's true of each of us.
Now, no cell says to the
other cell, I know
what you should do.
Because the guidance for every
cell comes to that cell.
You start with the idea that
wherever you are, that's it.
Every situation you're in,
whoever you're talking to,
whatever the circumstance.
If you are just standing there,
there to be of service,
there to be empty, there
to be of service, there
to not have an agenda.
Because that's what we've
done in our society--
you're taught that the way to
really handle a business
meeting is to go in beforehand,
what's your
intention, what's the
result you want,
which sounds so lovely.
It's so dark, because it
really means, how can I
exploit you?
How can I control you?
How can I manipulate you,
and how can i use you
to get what I want?
It has turned human interaction
transactional.
There's nothing beautiful
about that.
There's nothing enlightened
So instead, we walk into
any situation--
and remember, I'm not trying
to generate anything.
Creativity, the intelligence,
the higher intelligence of the
universe, knows exactly how
you and I meeting in this
conversation can best be used,
how it fits into you learning
what you need to learn, how it
fits into me learning what I
need to learn.
If you and I trigger each
other, that's no
less, by the way.
All I need to know is that
this situation is an
invitation to me to rise to the
highest version of myself
that I can be, to be kind, to
just be available, to be in
the present with you.
And then life will take us
wherever we best serve.
And literally, it comes out of
quote-unquote left field.
Out of the blue.
When people say to you, I just
met him out of the blue.
We just happened
to be talking.
When you live that way and you
see it and things just happen,
that's why it is Hogwarts.
It is.
It's like, oh, just
what I needed just
happened to be there.
Why?
Because I wasn't trying to make
something happen, she and
I were just talking and being
kind and compassionate, really
caring about each other.
And next thing I know, you, who
is exactly what we needed,
just happened to be
sitting there.
The chaotic universe is the one
that occurs, OK, now what
is it we need and how can we get
it, and who can we find?
I mean, there's an aspect of
that, if it's of service to
the higher.
Does that makes sense?
So it's none of my business
what any of you
are supposed to do.
It's none of your business
what I'm supposed to do.
All we're talking about is
showing up in any room you
happen to be in, knowing that
the universe, whenever
anybody's consciousness is how
can I serve and I'm available
today, use me.
Use my hands.
Use my feet.
And it goes without saying,
the universe
can use smart people.
A lot of them.
Necessary.
Now.
Doesn't that make sense?
Hello.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I often find myself
being conflicted when a
thought comes to my mind that
say I need to serve.
For example, animals.
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON:
Serve what?
AUDIENCE: Animals.
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: Animals.
AUDIENCE: Or any gods,
for that matter.
The thought that comes to my
mind is that a, yes, you are
trying to be present and you're
working on yourself.
Is this a calling that's coming
from that truth or
higher self, or whatever you
might want to call it?
Or is it just your mind, your
smart cell in your mind just
saying, just presenting
you another
way of feeling fulfilled?
So for instance, the thought
might say, OK, you need to--
you really like helping animals,
so you should do it.
But then, another thought comes
that that could also be
an egoic thing.
How do you know it's coming from
your true self, or is it
your purpose--
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: It's love
for another-- it's love and
the end of suffering for
another sentient being.
The ego does not want you to
give yourself to love and the
diminishment of suffering of
other sentient beings.
Any voice that is leading to
love and the end of suffering
for other sentient beings
is the voice of spirit.
Now if you have some egoic
motivations around it, like,
oh, those people who--
like me if I do that,
then you check that.
But the impulse--
and by the way, I want
to say this.
You have now been in a room
where for 30 minutes, we've
spoken these kinds of ideas.
It's very difficult to
lie to yourself.
When you're in a room,
ideas grow
stronger when being shared.
This is a good time to
listen to yourself.
You said serving animals
three times.
Yes, that's what your heart
is leading you to do.
That's your assignment.
And we all have different
assignments.
Some cells are supposed to be
working with the spleen, some
on the liver, some
on the heart.
Your assignment is animals.
Somebody else's assignment
is the environment.
is sex trafficking.
Somebody else's assignment
is hunger and poverty.
is--
because every cell is directed
to go where it
could be best of use.
AUDIENCE: That's helpful.
And also, if you could talk
about, a lot of texts, in
different ways, say that no
matter what action you do, it
doesn't matter.
It all comes down to, again,
the consciousness with
which you do it.
So irrespective of whether I
do this or not, should I
always be centered on that?
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: Only an
entitled, narcissistic era of
Americans could say
such a thing.
17,000 children on this planet
starve to death every day.
In addition to that, there are
15,000 adults who are dying.
There are a billion people
living on this planet on a
dollar and a half,
and less, a day.
There are a billion above that
living on $2 and less a day.
This is why the world looks at
us and can't figure out what
we're thinking.
It doesn't matter what we do.
Yeah, that's real easy for us to
say here, isn't it, because
we're all pretty
much making it.
See, that's the thing.
The club in America, and in most
of Western civilization,
if you're in the club,
it's a great place.
I love the club.
The club's been good to me.
Not enough people can get into
the club these days.
And some of the things that are
happening outside the club
are genuinely horrific.
So the last thing that we need
to be saying to ourselves or
to each other is that what we
do doesn't really matter, as
long as we have what,
loving intention.
What does that even mean?
And there are people getting
paid to say that.
What?
How easy can it get?
Oh, that's cool.
I don't have to do anything
to help anybody.
I don't have to do anything to
stop oppression or injustice,
or human suffering, because
I'm just thinking love.
There is nothing spiritual,
nothing spiritual about that,
nothing high minded
about that.
There is no legitimate, serious
spiritual path that
ever makes you feel like you
have a pass, you get a pass,
on addressing the suffering
of other living things.
AUDIENCE: What are some
things you do to
maintain your presence?
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON:
Well, I'm a student
of a course in miracles.
There are many, many
serious spiritual
paths on this planet.
Some of them are religious.
Some of them are spiritual.
Some of them are
pretty secular.
It doesn't matter
the language.
If it's in a secular--
If it's in a spiritual or
religious context, it will, by
definition, involve daily
prayer and meditation.
Because the idea here is that
the consciousness of the human
race is dominated by fear.
And so enlightenment is an
unlearning of the thought
system of fear and accepting,
instead, the thought system
that's actually natural to us,
which is that we love each
other and we want to connect.
But we are taught from the
time we are born on this
planet, we're taught, we're
separate from each other, that
there's only so much abundance,
so we have to
compete to get some, which is
what that book, "Law of Divine
Compensation", is about.
Rather than converting to the
thought system that there's
more than enough
for everybody.
And if you get the goods, it's
not like there's less than me.
So for me to just bless you,
if I don't rejoice that you
got abundance, then what I'm
programming my mind to
self-sabotage any time abundance
comes to me.
Because once I realize there's
only of us here, if I begrudge
you, I'll begrudge myself.
So you walk around knowing that
there's enough for everybody.
But this is more than an
intellectual shift, more than
a rational shift, because
it's so at odds.
So it really is a retraining
process.
Just like you go to the gym
to work your muscles.
And let's say I'm
working my arms.
OK.
And I have to do accumulated
repetitions.
Why?
Because after a certain age,
my muscles are headed down.
So I work against gravity for
the anti-gravitational force.
That's how you build your
physical muscles so
that you can move.
Spiritual exercise
is the opposite.
You're working on your
capacity to be still.
So you do spiritual exercises,
forgiveness, compassion work,
meditation, prayer,
transcendental--
that there's so many.
Here in this part of the
country, they're everywhere.
Different--
and if you don't know--
many people in a position
where you know what your
spiritual path is,
but you know you
haven't been doing it.
A lot of people with their
spiritual paths are kind of
like, I paid the dues
at the gym.
I just don't go.
Other people in this room might
be thinking, I don't
even know what mine would be.
If you and your heart make
a movement towards I'd be
interested, books will
fall at your feet.
And then when we do
that, we're honing
our attitudinal muscles.
We're honing our attitudinal
muscles, so that if I see you
and I see something
Id be tempted to
judge, I don't judge.
Or if I do judge, I
stop and go, oh.
And then the interesting thing
about that is whereas physical
musculature gives you the you
can move, you can move,
spiritual musculature,
attitudinal musculature gives
you the capacity to be still.
You have impulse control.
You don't say that
stupid thing.
You don't send that dumb text.
You don't push the send
button when my--
technology has really given
us more power to blow it.
Because, I'm going to
tell him right now.
No, don't send that text.
Right, right.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: We have "un
you send" at Google.
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: Good.
Good.
Yeah, I know.
But then, doesn't it say-- then
it says that you undid
something, so the person knows
that you unsent it.
I've been there.
OK.
I know what you were
going to--
OK.
But the other thing about that
illness is not only impulse
control, but the wisdom mind can
get through the clutter.
There's a term in both Judaism
and Christianity, the small,
still voice within.
We meditate because the ego
mind, the voice of the world,
speaks first and it
speaks loudest.
And we meditate to cultivate a
capacity for a wisdom voice.
It's that feeling of, oh, I
just got this great idea.
I got it.
I'm sure that happens here
at Google every day.
In various places, somebody
says, oh my God, I got it.
Well, hundreds of years ago,
they would have said, the muse
spoke to them.
It's the same thing.
This relates a little bit--
but it was fascinating to me.
I read an article in the
newspaper about a bunch of
brain scientists from MIT and
Harvard and all over, some of
the greatest brain scientists,
who got together.
And they were having a meeting
about Alzheimer's.
Well, not specifically
Alzheimer's, about memory loss
in older people.
And they were working
on a theory.
And this theory was the idea
that not all memory loss is a
devolutionary factor in the
functioning of the brain.
But rather, they were talking
about the idea that as the
brain gets older, in its genius
it would say, I don't
need any more of
those details.
I get the pattern.
I don't need those details.
I already jumped to the higher
understanding of what the
pattern is.
And all these brain scientists
were all excited about this.
Everybody at the table was
talking about it, because they
were all getting it, and they
were all recognizing this, and
really turned on by this idea
that there's something in the
brain that seems to be weaker,
but it's actually stronger and
it said that it dropped the
details for a reason, because
it's recognizing the
higher patterns.
And they're all excited.
And somebody said, oh my God,
what do we call this?
This is amazing.
What do we call this?
And all of a sudden,
it was just silent.
Because everybody got
it at the same time.
Somebody threw up their pencil
and went, wisdom.
And that's what we're after.
But we don't have time to wait
'til we're old to be wise.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I want to know, when
you talk about the law of
divine compensation and you
compare it with the law of
gravity, there must be some
strong conviction that you
have that that's a real law that
has some basis for its
functioning and you have
convinced yourself that that
really exists and
may perhaps some
mechanism by which it works.
So I wonder if you could give us
some of that insight which
you believe that this is a
true law that can be--
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: The only
arbiter of that conviction is
experience.
And I can't give that to you.
So I would say to you, for
instance, why don't you try it
some time, just in case.
Now conviction is a
force multiplier.
So a lot of people, for
instance, there might be some
people in this room who, let's
say, have been through
recovery, the 12 steps of
Alcoholics Anonymous.
There are many times--
I always say, in my work,
people don't come to me
because things are going well.
Oftentimes, when things are
going well in people's lives,
they listen to people like me
and think we're a bunch of woo
woo crazy people.
But then they get diagnosed with
cancer, or their child is
on heroin, or their wife goes
through rehab, or they get
divorced, or whatever.
And there's something that
happens when we're like on our
knees, and we're willing to hear
things that maybe we were
not interested in
hearing before.
And then we recognize, because
it cannot not happen, whether
it's the course in miracles
or 12 steps of Alcoholics
Anonymous, these steps cannot
not work, any more than when
you go to the gym.
I mean, if you do it,
it's going to work.
If I do enough leg lifts, my
thighs are going to change.
It's going to not not work.
You don't say that I have
such faith in the gym.
I just know how it works.
If you go through enough in your
own life where you feel
you really messed up, and you
tried to be a better person,
you tried to clean things up,
you tried to be more loving,
you took responsibility for
your life, you made amends
where you needed to, you
apologized for it, you try to
be more integrous, you try to
be more responsible, you try
to be more reliable,
your life changes.
And then it's not just that you
believe it, it's that you
experience it.
Belief doesn't mean anything.
There are people who say they
believe in God and kill people
in the name of God.
And there are people who don't
even believe in God, but they
love each other and they
stand on love.
So they're conspiring with
divinity, even if they don't
yet believe in it.
It's not about belief.
It's about experience.
So where do I get
my conviction?
My experience.
My conviction.
My life.
I notice that when I do my
best to practice what I
preach, my life really works.
And when I don't practice what
I preach, those are the
moments when I experience
chaos, disorder and
unhappiness.
So I'm pretty convinced.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for all you are.
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON:
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And for all
the inspiration you
bring to the world.
And I've seen you already.
And so my question is
about presence.
But the question is more about
how do you deprogram yourself
from fear to love, from
scarcity to abundance?
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: OK.
Enlightenment, the course in
miracles as alignment, begins
as an abstract intellectual
construct.
We all know these principles
by now, love, compassion,
blah, blah, blah.
But that is so counter to the
thinking of the world.
It's easy to sit in a room
talking about how we should
all love each other.
It's when we go out of this
room, that life is constant
temptation.
So the spiritual journey is the
abstraction, taking the
journey from the head
to the heart.
And that is what that attitude
we're honing, you're honing
new attitudinal muscles.
And just like with the physical
gym, the repetitions,
the accumulated repetitions of
that which opposes gravity,
after a certain age, whether
it's your physical muscles or
your thought ones, if you're
not working on keeping them
up, they're headed down.
And you accumulated repetitions,
and that's what a
serious spiritual path is.
And that's what meditation is.
And that's what prayer is.
I'm a student of the
course in miracles.
The course does not claim
to be for everybody.
If it's for you, you know it.
There is some path
for everybody.
There are the world's great
religions that have, they all
have their mystical teachings
which are at the core, so
separate from the organized
dogma and doctrine.
There are meditation paths.
Every person--
there is, like I said, if you're
interested in it, it'll
occur to you.
It'll be at somebody's house.
It'll be a book on the
floor, whatever.
But it does take
daily practice.
And I think that a very
important issue that's also
very similar to physical
exercise, you never get to a
point where you've done so much
physical exercise that
you look in the mirror
and go, cool, I don't
have to do that anymore.
On any day that you stop
doing it, the muscles
will head back down.
And the same until you're, I
guess, the level of the avatar
or the enlightened master or
something, which I'm not, so I
can't know.
But I know at the level beneath
that, the fact that
you did it yesterday, then
maybe you ought to do it
today, because today will be a
whole new set of temptations.
And the higher you get,
the higher the study.
So the way life operates, in my
experience and everybody I
know, is hey, you're
doing really well.
God, that was really nice the
way you handled that.
That was really great.
You were really dignified,
elegant, wise.
How's that?
Because it comes from left
field, you get triggered, and
then you go later, oh.
But in a real spirit journey,
the word try
is not a bad word.
We all fall off the
spiritual wagon.
We say things.
We do things.
Not our best moments.
We get up, and even that
becomes part of
what teaches us.
Because we really want to do it
better next time, and life
will always give us
the opportunity.
But that's where the whole idea
of atonement comes in.
The atonement principle is an
amazing principle that you get
a cosmic reset when you admit
what you've done wrong.
You acknowledge, you take
responsibility for your mistakes.
And then--
this is where in a religious
narrative, this is where
Buddha came 500 years
before Jesus.
Buddha talked about action
has a reaction.
Every action has a reaction.
And then Jesus said, yes, but
in a moment of grace, the
karma is burned.
So the Eastern religions are
really into the recognition
that every action
has a reaction.
Every thought creates
form at some level.
Every thought determines how
you will then behave.
Every action will have
a consequence.
And that is the great gift of
the Eastern perspective.
The Western perspective is, and
I can do something about
it if I don't like that, that
I can, that I can interrupt
the pattern of karma through
atonement, through recognizing
the mistake I made, through
asking forgiveness through
whatever the practice is.
And that's really where-- and
whole nations need atonement
sometimes, just like
individuals do.
And that's very much where
the United States is.
Germany really--
you have to give
it to Germany.
Germany flat out owned it.
And I say that as a Jew.
So Jews are very
aware of that.
They owned it.
From the reparations to the
museums, to the everything.
They owned it.
And that, I think, from the
metaphysical perspective, is
one of the reasons why Germany
is doing so well today.
The universe supported it.
The United States, for whatever
reason, takes this
corporate, never apologize,
never explain and never
apologized.
Terrible.
But whether it has to do with
our refusal to apologize for
slavery, our refusal to
apologize for Vietnam, our
refusal to apologize for Iraq,
we won't allow ourselves.
As individuals we will, but the
nation has some terrible
karma, because of this infantile
belief that if I
accept responsibility,
I'm somehow--
that that's weakness.
When in fact, spiritually, for
an individual and for a
nation, that's strength.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for coming today.
You've come up in my life
outside of work and it's
really special to have
you here at work.
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON:
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to actually
ask about your experience of
integrating or speaking this
language in environments or
communities where the language
isn't spoken.
How do you practice that?
What has your experience been?
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON:
So much has changed
in the last 30 years.
I mean, when I started my
career, people would hear the
things I was saying and go,
oh, my God I've never even
heard these things.
I've never even thought
about these things.
Today people go, oh, that's
exactly what we were talking
about yesterday.
That's so interesting.
It has become a mainstream
conversation.
Now, your friends, if you
can't talk it, now
you're like, so--
and then, whether you talk about
it in spiritual terms or
secular terms, it's not that
difficult, because it's just
about love.
It's about compassion.
So for people for whom the word
God would seem like a
freak, you don't use
the word God.
God himself doesn't care.
It's just a word.
It's love.
It's the experience of our
loving each other.
Like in "Les Miserables" where
it say to love another person
is to see the face of God.
So more and more, I find it
easier and easier, because
it's really hit a tipping
point in the culture.
It's mainstream, which is, I
think, a very good thing.
Does that make sense?
Don't you find that?
Sometimes we have to just
change-- if you can't drop
your jargon, then you're
not deep enough into
the inquiry, anyway.
AUDIENCE: I was curious, I
recently started learning
about Viktor Frankl
and logotherapy.
And he talks about the purpose
or meaning in life.
So I wonder how much of that had
an experience or influence
on your thoughts or not?
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON: Very much
so, of course, as I think it's
a classic in anybody's
development of this
understanding.
There's only one truth spoken
in many different ways.
And I think Viktor Frankl is
one of those people who,
because of his own personal
experience and his own
personal suffering, has had
tremendous, obviously, moral
authority and effect
on generations.
And yes, he has been on mine,
as there's nothing like
someone who's been there and
says this stuff works.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming.
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON:
Thank you.
God bless, everybody.
Thank you so much
for having me.
Thank you.